Zooey Deschanel has brought her humour
charm and vocal stylings to both the big
and small screens now there seems to be
very little on the horizon for her so
why aren't we seeing more of one of
Hollywood's most likable stars Zooey
Deschanel might not be popping up on
your TV screen as much as she used to
because let's face it she could really
use some time off she's been acting
consistently since her teen years when
she broke out in the late 90s and early
2000s with roles and films like Mumford
and almost famous along with an
appearance in an offspring video
remember the offspring yeah she's been
doing this acting thing for a while over
the last couple of decades Deschanel has
appeared in dozens of movies large and
small and provided voice work for
animated projects all that plus she
starred in more than 100 episodes across
seven seasons of the single-camera
comedy new girl Deschanel even served as
a producer on the project and co-wrote
and performed the theme song in short
she's probably a little tired she's
earned her hiatus and won't likely
missed the grind of a 22-episode TV
season for a while Zooey Deschanel rose
to fame by portraying a movie character
archetype that soon turned into a trite
character cliche film writer Nathan
Raven coined the term Manic Pixie dream
girl to describe Kristen Dunst as
character in the 2005 movie
Elizabethtown a young woman who quote
exists solely in the fevered
imaginations of sensitive writer
directors to teach broodingly soulful
young men to embrace life and it's
infinite mysteries and adventures sounds
a lot like the roles Deschanel played in
500 days of summer The Hitchhiker's
Guide to the galaxy and yes man huh
Deschanel is regularly identified with
this concept and the death of its
popularity could hurt her chances to get
cast
she's also nearing 40 a little too old
to be playing girls and she's honestly
too accomplished a performer to play
such thankless roles anymore with new
girl taking up most of her time Zooey
Deschanel hasn't appeared in all that
many major movies in the 2010s
she only co-starred in two big
live-action outings during that time the
medieval comedy your highness and the
music industry satire rocked the casbah
not only did both movies flop but they
flopped spectacularly Deschanel played
the damsel in distress in your highness
a swords and sorcery stoner adventure
alongside Natalie Portman James Franco
and Danny McBride it earned a
disappointing 21 million dollars less
than half of its 50 million dollar
budget meanwhile Forbes named rock the
Kasbah the biggest flop of 2015 for both
commercial and critical reasons it
grossed about 3 million dollars against
the 15 million dollar production budget
film reviewers hated it - it's cursed
with an abysmal 8% rating on Rotten
Tomatoes no that's crazy real that's a
dumb after a string of unsuccessful
movies Deschanel might be a bit iffy
about returning to the big screen and we
can't blame her after all the talents
not always at fault which might be why
after starring on her own show for the
better part of a decade Deschanel just
might have lost interest in playing
supporting roles in the big-budget
high-profile commercially minded movies
that made her a household name instead
she might just return the smaller more
intimate films her performance in the
low-key 2003 romantic drama all the real
girls one day Chanel nominations and
awards that set the tone for bankable
movie and TV star day Chanel's parallel
career as an indie stalwart with roles
and well received and thoughtful fares
such as winter passing our Idiot Brother
gigantic and the Driftless area it's a
safe bet that the next time we see your
in a feature film it might be a festival
entry or some hidden gem deep within
Netflix independent drama category Zooey
Deschanel may have had a hard time
scheduling acting gigs in 2013 because
her side career as a musician was
successful while filming the 2007 movie
the go-getter star Deschanel met major
indie music figure M Ward G acted he did
the soundtrack and the director thought
they ought to recorded too wet together
they did and their band was off and
running a little bit folk a little bit
classic country she and him play
whimsical pop music with Ward handling
the guitar work and Deschanel taking the
lead vocals since 2009 they released six
albums of mostly original music plus two
Christmas records and a covers
collection they've had some success with
their singles in the Sun and thieves and
they play a lot of super chill music
festivals each summer Deschanel just
can't be delighting fans with movies
when she's up there on stage warbling
adorable old-fashioned love songs but
hey we'll take what we can get
[Applause]
[Music]